it's not a formula it's not paint by
numbers
but it at least is a way to say here's
how i'm going to start my work today
before you and kathy wrote the defining
moment what was your process for writing
characters
kathy and i approach
character from lots of different angles
because
characters are
slippery
critters that you know have a lot of
facets a lot of dimensions
for many years we have
asked these questions about what are the
moments that define these characters
so that's a really important part of
what we've always done
we also
we have a set of what we call the hero
questions
where we ask things like what does this
character want
because every character is driven by
by some intention
uh and then we ask how does this
character need to grow and change
because the most interesting characters
uh very often do
transform in some way or even adjust not
all characters and all genres transform
but
uh often there's at least a small
growth or adjustment in them and that's
that's satisfying that's where some of
the emotion comes from for the audience
we ask what terrible thing will happen
if the hero doesn't get what they want
and that helps us zero in on the stakes
of the story
uh for the the external stakes and we
ask what terrible thing will happen if
they don't grow and change
in the way they need to
and that gets at the internal stakes
and we ask
how's the audience going to relate to
this character what are they going to be
rooting for
in relation to this
character because we're really convinced
that
if we are not
rooting for our protagonist
we're not going to be invested
emotionally in the outcome of the story
and so if we don't care
we're bored
we also
um
we've got a list of character
qualities that i've stolen from my
friend
uh dr sydney showers
and so i call those dr showers eight
character traits
and she is a list she's a
gifted writer
who's just compiled this list of
character traits
and they include some of the things that
are
included in the hero questions but she
asks some other things she asks about a
character's drive
and by that she means what is that motor
even outside of
the specific problem that's being solved
in this movie there's a killer asteroid
headed toward earth and so our goal is
to
save the earth
what drives that character the rest of
the time
are they a person who's all about
protecting people
throughout their lives everywhere or is
it
about
they're driven by recognition
and so i want to
save the earth because it'll make me
famous
and so that's that's the idea of the
character's drive
she thinks about the character's genius
and her idea is that every character has
some strength or genius whether it's
high iq or in the case of forrest gump
it's not high iq but it's purity of love
purity of heart
could be your great cello player
it's um it's something
that is a strength a character has
and then she thinks about
uh
characters
flaw
and also
their weakness as two different things
the weakness she thinks of as
uh just an inability to do something i
don't write comedy that's my weakness
i'm sure
one element in a very long list the flaw
she thinks of more as a moral failure
a person's proud cruel selfish
fearful something
[Music]
all of
all of these are just questions
that prompt
me prompt kathy to think about our
characters
and then we also get some insight into
our characters by letting them talk
so
when i was writing
with kathy our german film after the
truth
that's a movie that's about
the auschwitz doctor joseph mengele
and
i knew that i needed to
capture his voice as part of his
character what kinds of things does
mengelis say
and so i sat down one afternoon and i
just kind of wrote a rant
in his voice i just sort of allowed
myself to
inhabit that character i read everything
i could find out about him every word
that we knew he had written
and
and i inhabited that character and just
wrote in his voice and i wrote a lot it
wasn't dialogue it was more of a
kind of a blog post from joseph mengele
and and then i
whatever the opposite of inhabited
disinhabited that character and i never
went back in there
but i was able to just go back
to
those pages
of
journal entry or blog post in that
character's voice as kind of a tuning
fork
that allowed me to write in that
character's voice
and i've done that for other characters
as well as a way of
pinning down
a character's voice
and being able to then draw on that
it's almost
i don't know anything about making
sourdough bread but i think that you've
got this starter and you just you keep
you just need a little bit of it to get
the dough going and that's how that
works
you've got that starter and that allows
you then to
write
dialogue for any scene from that
character
it's it's a messy iterative process
often i will think about a character as
i'm going to sleep at night
and
i'll wake up and have some new insight
into them
i i really think that it's just it's
we need different strategies to just get
us coming back over and over and over
again to our characters and giving us
ourselves the opportunities to make more
discoveries about them
and just to go back to this metaphor
about the the sourdough starter if i
understand it correctly that you can
keep some of the starter still there
in a cupboard covered up so it sounds
like two
maybe there's with this checklist that's
like the starter that you're keeping
because you're you're going to go back
to this checklist that you talked about
in the book that you have
what is it like 20
questions or so yeah so the
i don't even know how many hero
questions plus
if we add dr showers eight character
traits that probably does get us to
about 20.
um yeah right
writing a movie especially
or writing a tv series
it's a massive project and
having a starter
is uh is a big help uh just a place to
grab that first thread and and start
pulling so it's
it's not a formula it's not paint by
numbers
but it at least is a way to say here's
how i'm going to start my work today
and
make contact
with this character
i've
for the first time in my life i directed
a short film
recently
and
so i had to write the script i did all
of my write it writerly character stuff
but then there were weeks of prep and
pre-production casting working with
actors and then shooting
which allowed me to just keep coming
back to these characters over and over
and over again what i discovered is
you keep learning new things every time
you sit down with your characters
you learn more and more and more and
eventually it's more than you can fit in
the movie
so things start overflowing and falling
out
but far better to come at this work
with
this overflowing
just richness
of
character and knowledge about these
characters that you can't even fit it
all into the movie
i think that's what the audience wants
is a real density of ideas
we just keep discovering more
and the only way the audience is going
to keep discovering more is if we have
before them
discovered more and more and more how
has the defining moment changed the way
you write characters
i think that
i began my writing life as a pretty
lazy guy with
low ambitions i wanted to be just good
enough to get to play in the game
which is ridiculous because nobody who's
aiming to be mediocre gets to play in
the game
kathy is much more about let's
not do the least we can let's do the
most we can
so from the
the moment that we learned about
defining moments
kathy has been all about let's do our
homework let's really dig into these
characters
and
i've
i've had to grow into the discipline of
it
and as i've
as i've been willing to invest the
effort
into
spending time to really deeply
understand my characters rather than
rushing ahead because i can't wait to
write that scene where
the thing blows up
my writing gets better and deeper
[Music]
so
i'm excited now every time i approach a
new character
because
i am
i'm just asking
i'm asking all these questions and
requiring myself not to rush ahead but
to take the time to really enrich
the characters enrich the script the
script i'm writing right now i'm
actually in a rewrite process
where i'm
i i paused
and did all this defining moment work
because i felt like a hypocrite you know
having written the book i need to
actually do this
made wonderful discoveries
and i'm now in the process
of
of enriching the script with all of
those insights
uh so for me it's
it's made my writing i think objectively
better richer more emotional
and the character is just more
interesting
so when you you first started as a
writer what were some of the characters
what were some of the the films that you
wanted to emulate aside from
you know we talked about ordinary people
yeah so besides ordinary people um the
deer hunter was also a film that was uh
very influential on me
and then um
this is completely
from a different genre
raiders of the lost ark that's just for
me so much fun
uh steven spielberg really understands
how to tell a story with action it's not
random action
and
we are really with the character in the
midst of it we understand
what's going on what has to be achieved
what all the threats are
and then he tumbles you in that film out
of the frying pan into the fire time
after time you end one action sequence
and you tumble
into the beginning of the next one
so that one for me is just a lot of fun
and
teaches me the movie
movie going
can be fun it doesn't have to just be
you know this emotional
ripping open of the soul
uh
the elephant man
is a film that i really love
and
um
a real character
study a study of
the connection between
two characters who are very different
and in that movie
it's the audience that's transformed
so the first time that the elephant man
is seen on screen
we
like cover our faces and turn away and
horror at his hideousness
he doesn't change but by the end of that
movie we are like on a close shot
of his face
and all we can see is his beauty
he didn't change but we changed
and i love that
film that story
can do that that it can change what we
see
you